i've been watching the pam and tommy
thing no is that good i'm enjoying it
it's great it's like there's a whole
scene where uh spoiler alert uh where
his like penis talks
i heard about that that's [ __ ]
hilarious i saw the article today we're
having a penis renaissance there's been
a lot of penises this year yeah
renaissance penis songs good yeah
yeah the penis is back there
glenn's really happy with that
very happy i think they're i think it's
well overdue
that we have a
because we've been showing other stuff
for a long time and it's time to show
those dicks guys it's time to get your
dicks out and show everybody what you've
got yeah not at work not at work
don't take your dick out on no no no no
no but if you're in a movie take your
dick out and let's see what you've got
as long as that's the right place for it
it's scripted and everyone they've
cleared the set we've agreed there's a
time and a place for everything and the
time and the place is when you're doing
a movie